ich bin ein bisschen mehr du willst ein
taubes nüsschen jahren taube investieren
wir taube taube tauben bisschen ja hallo
leute ich es wieder eure mal waren und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute machen wir endlich
den dreifachen doppel nuss becher aus
dem spongebob schwammkopf will
da der film 2004 rauskam werden ihn
wahrscheinlich viele von euch nicht
kennen denn das ist schon 14 jahre her
deswegen fast sich einmal kurz die story
zusammen bosch verbraucht darauf der
manager von der neuen krossen krabbe
zwei zu werden ob er es jetzt wird
verrate ich euch nicht da könnt ihr
selber mal den film schaut auf jeden
fall wird diese ganze story unterbrochen
von plankton der natürlich wieder einen
bösen plan ausgeheckt und ich sag mal so
er hat etwas gestohlen und irgendwo
anders hin gebracht und spongebob und
patrick müssen diesen gegenstand wieder
zurückholen und treffen auf ganz große
abenteuer und das ist alles super witzig
im toll weil wir sind 2000 dessen
ungefähr bei minute 17 sitzen spongebob
und patrick in der tauben bisschen bar
und bestellen sich den dreifachen doppel
muss welche und der dreifache doppeln
sprecher sieht witzig und cool und süß
aus dass viele von euch gefragt haben ob
ich ihn mal nachmachen kann und das
werden wir heute tun ich habe mir sogar
einen seemann zurückgekauft ja sieht er
aus wie ein seemann zu und ich finde ich
sehe aus wie so ein eisverkäufer was
passt ja auch dieses kufi maskottchen
ist ja eine erdnuss und man sieht
überall erdnüsse das heißt es wird
wahrscheinlich erdnussbutter eis sein
huracán sherlock holmes alle schlauen
unter euch wissen was das bedeutet
ich habe mir eine eiscreme maschine
gekauft aber nur wenn steffen henssler
drauf ist wisst ihr dass diese
eismaschine gesandte stephen bailey
verbessert würde so wir mal mit dir
zusammen kochen stefan alter schon
gehört bei einer als maschine ist es
wichtig dass man 24 stunden vorher die
schale in eine gefriertruhe tut was ich
auch getan habe aber bevor wir das eis
machen können müssen wir erst mal die
creme mache ich war ehrlich gesagt so
naiv und dachte dass man einfach alle
zutaten in einer eismaschine reinmacht
und am ende rauskommt aber es ist doch
ein bisschen komplizierter diese
flüssigkeit zuzubereiten
jetzt zeige ich euch aber wie es geht
viel spaß beim letzten mal die
nudelmaschine und heute die eismaschine
ich fange an die italienerinnen mir zu
fühlen baby debug die buch und für
erdnussbutter eis brauchen wir 250 gramm
erdnussbutter oder auch pindakaas
erdnuss muss peanut butter oder partner
attraktiv
französisch ist einfach die längste
sprach der welt wie heißt dieses katrin
dong die snacks öffnung düster ostrowski
sprach ich ja sieht am titan emails zu
weise genau eine tüte vanillezucker 400
milliliter schlagsahne und das geht
direkt auf die hüften oder in den
hintern in den hinter mir auch nicht
schlecht an 250 milliliter laktosefreie
milch nein das darf natürlich jeder
andere milch auch sein
ich brauche die laktosefrei dann kommt
noch 130 gramm zucker dazu und zum
schluss 3 eickel und schon haben wir ein
passendes oster video frohe ostern leute
heute ist ja ostern sieht hier gar nicht
nach ostern aus dank mir später
und da hat er gebracht hat ist doch das
nehme ich das nämlich osterdekoration
zuerst geben wir 3 eigelb in eine
schüssel und dann kommen 130 gramm
zucker hinterher
und wenn wir es besonders süß mögen darf
der vanillezucker auch nicht fehlen
und jetzt wird alles zu einer
geschmeidigen masse verrührt das ist
doch mal eine geschmeidige masse für den
nächsten schritt müsst ihr den korb auf
dem kopf und erhitzt
jetzt wollen wir unsere milch erhitzt
aber nur leicht bittet sie darf nicht
kochen
37 unsere milch ist jetzt wirklich heiß
und jetzt kommt die eier masse dazu und
gut verrühren wenn eure creme fertig ist
wie bei mir er schaue mich als cremig
ist dann müsst ihr sie schnell in ein
anderes gefäß umfüllen wupsi du
probieren und zucker und jetzt tut ihr
die sahne dazu und die erdnussbutter und
wie hat das überhaupt verrühren grobian
und gut rühren unsere erdnuss als
mischung ist jetzt fertig sie schmeckt
so lecker um die masse muss jetzt
natürlich noch abkühlen dass wir sehen
die eismaschine tun können und wir sehen
uns dann wieder hell wie funktioniert
das denn und nun versuchen wir den
ganzen teil einer als maschine zu bauen
dann haben wir mal jetzt da dieses
abends die schale
aha so nein das café jetzt müssen wir
die maschine tun
deckel drauf und jetzt warten wir darauf
dass wir es bekommen
es ist nicht so spektakulär wie ich
dachte ich würde sagen wir warten uns
daraus ist das eis wird und dann sehen
wir uns gleich wieder das eis ist immer
noch nicht fertig und ich sitze hier
ungefähr seit einer stunde habe ich dann
wie flüssig das wäre aber nicht besser
wenn ich nicht einen plan b hätte und
dieser wieso man kauft sich einfach
fertiges erdnussbutter eis ich werde
dafür sind vielfach tun und vielleicht
wird ja später noch zu heiß wir arbeiten
jetzt erstmal damit sind die wahl wie
schmeckt super geschmeckt gibt man nicht
auf so ist das meine kinder dekoration
dieses eis welches ist ja ein wahres
kunstwerk würde ich jetzt mal schwer
wach und was wir für die dekoration
dieses alt brauchen ist kleine baby
banana und eine schokoglasur smarty
kombi schnüre last but not least
cocktail kirschen mit stil
ihr wisst gar nicht wie schwer das ist
cocktail kirchen mit spiel zu kriegen
ich musste das in so einem bar supply
laden kaufen also wo du sachen für gas
kaufen kannst da haben sie taktischen
mit stil
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn ich ein anständiges man sein möchte
brauche ich auch meinen hut viele
westler habt sogar lange nach einer
eisscholle gesucht die so ähnlich wie im
film aussieht und das ist das was ich
gefunden habe
ich finde das passt gut auf jeden fall
schon recht ähnlich unsere schokolade
muss jetzt in ein heißes wasserbad damit
sie schön flüssig wird und in der zeit
versuchen wir unsere leistung aufzubauen
wir brauchen jetzt unsere ben & jerry's
eis was uns heute den tagen hätte weil
das erdnussbutter als glaube ich nichts
geworden ist ich versuche mal das so
aufzuschneiden und einfach so drauf zu
stellen das müssen wir doch klappen oder
nicht also weil das hier schon so eine
form von vista ist meine ich wollte
immer schon waren die chips welche
aufschneiden und peter risse live
gesehen wie die leute so ben & jerry's
becher aufschneiden und dachte immer so
spektakulär ist das gar nicht ok oh mein
ja ich glaube so machen es auch bei
spongebob dieser kellner da geht immer
in den hintergrund
[Gelächter]
sido habe ich muss noch zurechtschneiden
ruiniert das ist einfach so ein eis
schneide
also leute investiert das geld nicht in
einer eismaschine kauft einfach ein
blödsinn und jason arbeit damit das
schwierige bei diesem 1 ist ja dass wir
diese band stücke irgendwie an das
eintragen kriegen müssen und meine idee
war jetzt mit so stießen bis so fest zu
machen und einfach ins zu stecken ich
weiß was funktioniert aber lass uns das
mal ausprobieren
jetzt muss aber auch ein stückchen
schnell eines ausschnitts für mich wie
in so einer challenge sie haben noch
fünf minuten dann ist das eis
geschmolzen
diesen bisschen braun die kommt hier
stecke ich jetzt den stil in die banane
rein und so kinder werden babys gemacht
na komm schon stelle immer vor ihr seid
mal und wir jemals ein fester denn je
zum glück ist das für mich deswegen
von anderen sollte okay ich kann schon
gescheitert war das stück über dem see
so wir brauchen jetzt hier um auch so
kleine ding für die kirchen hat dich an
mir fest wenn leben nichts er ist der
freundliche bus seitlich okay jetzt
kommt die schokosoße drauf so könnt ihr
das sehen
excuse me so jetzt kommt es hier darauf
dass kraft gegen die zeit
wer wird für mit vanessa oder die zeit
für mich lieber zum kochduell ok
kirschen erledigt bitte heide noch ein
bisschen länger aus einem schlechten
hatte ein blaues auge auf dem linken ein
grünes und seine nase ist pink und wir
brauchen einen mund mein gott es
geschafft also ich habe es geschafft das
schnitt zeit nur super schnell ja ein
bisschen derb ist er
und jetzt stellen wir natürlich wieder
da allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt
der dreifache doppel muss becher aus
braunschweig schwammkopf der film und
guten appetit meyer gutes gesicht er
sich zuerst
wenn das nicht so ein verdammt da
wettlauf gegen die zeit wäre dann wäre
auch alles in ordnung und falls ihr euch
mit eis auskennt vielleicht habt ihr
einen tipp warum ein anderes erdnuss eis
nicht hart geworden ist liegt es an der
laktosefreien nicht weil ich hab mich
vorhin gefragt ob es vielleicht die
laktosefreie milch ist darf man im natur
befreien will ich nicht zum eis machen
verwenden
ich habe davon noch nie was gehört aber
das könnt ihr mir immer sagen als
möglich so eine kirche mit problem wir
noch die banane
ich habe tatsächlich noch nie baby
banane gegessen eine kleine baby banana
[Musik]
schmecken wie normale banane
falls ihr weitere vorschläge habt aus
filmen oder serien geht man nach machen
soll
schreibt mir die kommentare und wenn
euch das video gefallen hat dann leiten
nicht vergessen abonniert den kanal um
kein neues video zu verpassen
vielleicht aktiviert auch mal in die
glocke weil es ist ja so dass youtube in
letzter zeit irgendwie den abonnenten
nicht mit dem neuen videos angezeigt
falls sie mein letztes video verpasst
habt da habe ich nudeln gemacht was
findet ihr hier
und ansonsten würde ich sagen schönes
leben
macht mal was verrücktes wie den freund
vorbei sprecher und dann
euro macht ich bin meint auer bisschen
ja du willst ein taubes
[Musik]